Jr is close to being mr. digital content
as anybody I can think of you
spearheaded development at aol.com at
TMZ now you're with Vox I think I know
what BuzzFeed is I think I know what
Gawker is I think I know what vice is I
don't know what Vox is what is Vox
simple way to look at it is we create
media brands high quality large media
brands like the ones that you mentioned
for a new generation of consumers that
prefer to consume their content
digitally so if you think about it in a
simple way great magazine companies like
Time Inc or Conde Nast great cable
companies like USA networks or Disney or
Comcast and now we're creating new media
titles The Verge Vox SB nation in the
same way and we're doing it within this
medium as opposed to cable or magazines
obviously it's funny that you mentioned
Conde Nast or maybe not so funny because
Conde Nast operated a portfolio of
magazines yes there was Conde Nast
Traveler but people know Conde Nast
better for example for Vanity Fair or
vogue do you see yourself more as the
sign Newhouse of digital publishing as
opposed to say the kind of company that
vice is becoming well we definitely take
a vertical eyes approach we think that
SB Nation for instance at being a sports
brand you can command more authority we
don't want to be another portal where
everything is just general we believe
that individual brands convey Authority
in their topics and their subject
matters so we focus on creating those
brands hiring subject matter experts but
an important thing is we hire web native
content creators journalists
storytellers and then we empower them
with tools to grow their audience we
have a digital publishing platform
called Corus a media platform the
combination of Korus and our talent has
led to our big growth you see your
talent as you describe them as
journalists right that's right
journalists and storytellers how do you
pay in the digital world how do you pay
for good journalism
US dollars no this is crazy
no seriously uh it's it's a model that
can support itself because what's
interesting is that brands big brands
and we work with most of the big ones
have the same challenge that we have
which is to communicate with digital
audiences to tell them stories to build
their brands how do you build a brand
you do it with storytelling as their
audience is migrated online they have
the same challenges so the business
model that we have is to help them tell
their stories to our predominately young
affluent audiences and craft that for
them and that's how we're able to create
a great business model I get the idea of
content specific brands but what
BuzzFeed and vice to draw a contrast
appear to have done successfully is
create brand awareness through attitude
and an attitude that permeates all of
their coverage why does that approach
not appeal to you well we believe in you
know we search one of our brands have
their own attitude if you talk to
someone who goes to an eater site or
someone who goes to SB Nation or someone
who goes to the verge those brands have
distinct voices and that's critical you
have to have that distinct voice big
communities of interest but again and
and by the way that adds up to over 85
million unique visitors every month so
it's grown and it's done very well so I
think we think we do have our attitude
but it's more rooted in quality and
authority I think there was a period
where a lot of web content couldn't be
trusted and we wanted to bring back that
trust we wanted to bring back that
quality and in doing so blue chip
advertisers can trust us and can spend
with us how why is it that Vox
isn't recognized let's say for the speed
at which you are growing well I
hopefully will be through interviews
such as this and other things and if and
if it's not then shame on me for for not
promoting but I think the real answer to
that question is each one of our
individual brands within its own
category does very well we don't we're
not a portal so you can't go to you can
go to Vox Mediacom but that's not one of
our brands much like Conde in the
analogy we
put the emphasis on each one of our
titles as opposed to the corporate
entity itself and how much of your
traffic is through social referral
somebody read something on Twitter see
something on Facebook and ends up at one
of your sites that way as opposed to
going it's our number one traffic source
although unlike a lot of other companies
we actually get a lot of direct traffic
to and again that speaks to the quality
of the brands the authority of the
brands and once we get someone on
Facebook or Twitter they tend to come
back directly to one of our sites so we
put a lot of emphasis on that we don't
game the system but we certainly use
those new platforms to get big audience
and how do you see yourself growing
starting new sites starting a new
audience in a call it Greenfield Way or
doing what you did with eater racked and
kerb and going and buying some of these
existing business we're so glad that we
got eater racked and curbed and now we
can put them on the course technology
platform that we manage and we're
starting to see great growth because of
that so we might invest in under
invested properties like that but
moreover our model is to grow our
existing sites Vox which is our general
news site just launched about two and a
half months ago and it's already up to
over seven million unique visitors and
in less than three months so gives us a
lot of confidence that we can grow
properties from the ground up most of
what you do is for lack of a better term
in text what's the future of video for
Vox media well actually you know we a
lot of what we do is in video so it's a
good question and we're continuing to
invest in video ever even more than ever
so we have a studio in New York City
where we produce our own video we work
with some very talented creators on
YouTube and Vimeo and other product
platforms and then we also work with
marketers to help them top into video
web and the social web as well so we are
big time believers in video and if I'm
going to draw an analogy I'd say we're
probably closer to a cable company than
we are to a magazine company so we we
certainly believe in it but we believe
in finding the right tools to tell the
right story sometimes that's video
sometimes it's text often it's a
combination of many of those things in
other formats as well